buonasera a tutti io inizio con il dirvi
che sono qui grazie a due persone che
hanno trasferito tutta la loro
personalità tutta la loro ricchezza
interiore a me e quindi sono qui
innanzitutto per testimoniare come la
storia personale di una persona sia la
storia di altre persone anche di altre
persone oltre che la propria
mi riferisco a mio nonno che faceva
l'agricoltore qui in umbria e mi
riferisco a mio fratello ragazzo
autistico di 28 anni l'agricoltura
sociale quindi partiamo dal che cos'è
è un meccanismo di governance in cui le
aziende agricole profit quindi
tradizionali diversificano la propria
attività storica implementando i servizi
socio sanitari parallelamente è tutto
questo è avvenuto nella realtà già da
alcuni anni la cooperazione sociale
quindi le realtà imprenditoriali non
profit hanno iniziato a spontaneamente a
convergere verso le zone rurali perché
perché il verde cura perché in mezzo ad
un bosco stiamo meglio tutti
semplificando al massimo da questa
conversione nasce appunto un ibrido un
innesto per usare un termine da
agricoltura appunto in cui due forme
societarie tradizionalmente distanti si
incontrano e nasce una forma di impresa
agricola sociale
guardiamo un attimo come come operano
come si opera in agricoltura sociale
sostanzialmente attraverso un processo
di democrazia partecipativa molto
paritaria molto trasversale e attraverso
il principio della sussidiarietà quindi
prendendo su se stessi
l'iniziativa per realizzare ciò che
manca quindi abbandonando un po la
classica ottica assistenziale questi
attori prototipi e gestiscono
diversificazione aziendale assistenza
terapeutica e andando oltre un
meccanismo che riqualifica le comunità
stesse quindi comunità che si uniscono
lavorano e lavorano per chi per loro
stesse perché perché l'agricoltura
sociale perché innanzitutto c'è bisogno
di sostenibilità ambientale spesso
queste aziende producono quasi sempre il
regime di agricoltura biologica sono ogm
free fanno una vera e propria tutela del
territorio e sappiamo che con il rischio
idrogeologico che abbiamo nel nostro
paese la sola presenza in certe zone di
certi attori garantisce la sostenibilità
proprio territoriale ed ambientale
c'è una spiccata multifunzionalità in
agricoltura sociale mi riferisco al
contadino che sta dimostrando come dalla
semplice coltura della ben nota zucchina
si possa passare a produzione di energia
produzione di servizi turistici
produzioni dei servizi educativi
pensiamo alle fattorie didattiche e
all'ultimo di recente in ordine
temporale ai servizi socio sanitari
abbiamo uno spettro di servizi che
possono essere realizzati in campagna
impressionante andiamo dal agriasilo
agri nido in cui ci sono i bambini a la
casa per la terza età per rappresentare
lo spettro attraverso un arco temporale
e la multifunzionalità non è soltanto
operativa in senso economico ma lo è
anche da un punto di vista di
inserimento lavorativo quindi sappiamo
che un soggetto con un particolare
svantaggio può passare tranquillamente
in un'azienda agricola per trovare la
propria posizione da la semina piuttosto
che il servizio al coperto in un back
office amministrativo di un agriturismo
alla sgranatura del dei legumi e tante
altre cose quindi multifunzionale nel
mercato multifunzionale nelle mansioni
in
c'è un welfare partecipativo io posso
testimoniarvi grazie all'esperienza
diretta che poi vi racconterò che non
c'è servizio all'interno del contesto
rurale che non venga negoziato per così
dire da tutti i portatori di interesse
c'è un approccio multi stakeholder cioè
se si deve parlare di come assistere la
persona autistica la persona autistica e
la prima ad essere tenuta in
considerazione e andando avanti nelle
varie nelle varie sfaccettature
professionali e umane che si incontrano
all'interno di questa realtà la voce
conta e le voci di tutti contano vengono
tutelati i beni comuni all'interno
dell'agricoltura sociale acqua terra
fossi zone montane zone periurbane aria
pensiamo a tutto quello che è l'insieme
dei anche dei mezzi anche del degli
immobili che troviamo in agricoltura che
purtroppo con l'abbandono di certe zone
era stato abbandonato e stava accadendo
in disuso molto importante l'ultimo
aspetto che è più legato alla governance
e alla gestione l'economia e il processo
di formazione educativa la fattoria
didattica sta dimostrando che l'aula
come setting è importante ma è
importante anche una formazione
esperienziale il bambino deve mettere le
mani in pasta deve utilizzare i sensi al
meglio all'interno di queste realtà
scopriamo tristemente purtroppo che
spesso l'aderenza alla realtà si
interrompe fin troppo presto nel
processo di vita di una persona tant'è
che i bambini non riconoscono la carota
domandano se l'uovo crescere all'albero
piuttosto che di vedere la mucca viola
ecco quindi attraverso
le semplici visite che si possono fare
le aziende agricole e viene recuperata
proprio l'aderenza alla realtà laddove
viene quello che mangiamo l'economia
sociale è il movimento diciamo così
economico al quale aderiamo economia
sociale è quella dell'impresa senza
scopo di lucro che non significa che non
deve raggiungere l'equilibrio aziendale
ma che non divide gli utili alla fine
dell'anno quindi non c'è una
massimizzazione del capitale per
ottenere degli stipendi stratosferici
c'è il principio della porta aperta per
cui tutti possono presentarsi e se
l'azienda gode di buona salute deve
tenere in considerazione le candidature
delle persone che si fanno avanti cioè
il principio della di una testa un voto
quindi ogni scelta è fortemente
democratica e quindi anche in questo
senso
l'agricoltura sociale si muove in una
dimensione di democrazia partecipativa
quello che ho pensato di realizzare
appunto grazie alle esperienze personali
è stata è stata la semente la semente
che parte con un centro diurno dove
dodici ragazzi autistici attualmente
nelle campagne di spello stanno
affrontando un percorso riabilitativo
che punta da una parte a mantenere le
abilità per un autonomia personale
abilità che i ragazzi hanno acquisito
nel corso della propria vita all'interno
della scuola e all'interno di altri
servizi e dall'altra a trasferire
abilità atte a un inserimento lavorativo
quindi il focus e trasferimento di
abilità per un impiego di qualsiasi tipo
con qualsiasi contratto per qualsiasi
monte ore abbiamo laboratori ergo
terapici facciamo comunicazione
aumentativa alternativa perché queste
persone funzionano diversamente e quindi
abbiamo abbandonato un po il principio
della solidarietà cioè noi non puntiamo
a rendere tutti uguali bensì permettiamo
agli uguali di essere diversi
siamo fraterni facciamo orticoltura
quindi abbiamo un pezzetto d'orto in cui
non si vedono spesso nascere gli ortaggi
o i fiori perché appunto ha uno scopo
terapeutico e facciamo esperienze con
animali abbiamo galline abbiamo alpaca e
altri le altre specie questo è un
particolare di un dell'attività che il
confezionamento delle specie che
coltiviamo c'è poi una parte o uno
spinotto quindi vengo al secondo modulo
dalla parte sanitaria
passiamo alla parte commerciale una
cooperativa agricola sociale in cui i
ragazzi riabilitati avviate all'interno
del centro di uno possono trovare un
lavoro vero per darvi dei dati due dei
ragazzi abbiamo avviato al lavoro dal
2011 ad oggi hanno firmato l'atto
costitutivo della cooperativa che
gestisce questa fattoria e sono
diventati si sono trasformati da
assistiti in soci lavoratori esonerando
anche lo stato dalla quota di assistenza
in termini monetari che rivolgeva a
queste persone c'è una produzione
biologica facciamo orticoltura frutta ci
sono allevamenti
c'è un agriturismo e un ristorante e
facciamo percorsi didattici con le
scolaresche
qui un particolare nelle nostre colture
che ovviamente sono sono biologiche
terza ed ultima parte abbiamo guardato
fuori dalle nostre finestre e abbiamo
detto molto probabilmente riusciremo ad
ottenere un bel successo facendo capire
ai nostri vicini cittadinanza altre
imprese agricole eccetera che i nostri
ragazzi non sono un peso ma sono
un'opportunità e quindi abbiamo
ragionato facendo marketing sociale
facendo un coinvolgimento creando
un'associazione temporanea di scopo con
l'università degli studi di perugia il
parco tecnologico dell'umbria
la confederazione italiana degli
agricoltori e cinque imprese profit che
confinano con noi e appunto abbiamo dato
vita a questo distretto in cui
fondamentalmente si sta insieme si
comunica
da cosa nasce cosa abbiamo fatto fiere
insieme scambiamo i canali
commerciali e facciamo sperimentazioni
attraverso progettazioni europee
questa è un particolare del di uno degli
eventi che realizziamo all'interno del
distretto
grazie a tutti